desde pequeña siempre estuve fascinada
por
me gustan tanto tanto las ciudades que
en mi último vacaciones del 2017 decidí
recorrer caracas de catia hasta petare
y parecía así como una misión imposible
mucha gente te diría pero por cuánto
tiempo toma no sé quién es aquí lo he
hecho alguna vez
caminar completo así si hay gente que lo
ha hecho
pero esa sensación de vivir la ciudad al
final no llegamos hasta petare llegamos
hasta altamira la verdad pero caminamos
desde propatria hasta estación de
altamira y caminar la ciudad nos
llevamos nada ningún riesgo y
simplemente verla con los ojos no tener
que estar pendiente de qué de qué foto
voy a tomar para montar y sister
solamente disfrutarla ver todas las
cosas que pasan en el camino todos los
parques que hay las plazas los negocitos
los museos fue fascinante uno dice
probar que museos en caracas y en esa
caminata
visitamos y entramos a más de ocho
museos entonces cuando uno le están
dando las ciudades y luego se da cuenta
que creció y vive en un país donde nueve
de cada diez personas viven en ciudades
entonces uno trata de indagar más sobre
este tema de la ciudad y por qué vivir
en ciudades pues para mí vivir en
ciudades significa estar expuesto a la
cultura compartir un espacio con gente y
esa gente puede ayudarte a crecer a
desarrollarte a ser mejor hay muchas
cosas maravillosas las ciudades
hay una cosa muy sencilla de que si
somos más que vivimos juntos compartimos
costos y entonces podemos tener mejores
servicios mejor equipamientos sin
embargo hay una parte que no tiene todos
los beneficios de vivir en ciudad que no
tiene todos los museos que no tiene todo
el transporte público que necesita para
funcionar que no tiene todos los
servicios básicos a eso algunos
técnicamente le llamamos asentamientos
informales
o popularmente le llamamos los barrios
de caracas
entonces cuando tenemos una ciudad
dividida entre la gente que vive en un
sector y la gente que vive en otro
tenemos una segregación urbana y esa
segregación empieza por ponernos
etiquetas hablamos de esa gente que vive
en el cerro y tú te metes para allá
cuidado y te roban ese chamo tiene cara
de malandro y empezamos a ponerle muchas
etiquetas a la gente que ven una sola
ciudad pero también la gente que en esa
zona también le pone etiquetas al otro
lado voy a bajar a caracas aquellas
gentes de las urbanizaciones y si yo
vivo en la ciudad formal pero no
exactamente en una organización de las
organizaciones ahí vienen las gringas o
como muchas veces me dicen pero pero
mira el y tú qué vienes todos los días
para acá tú eres de acá y yo no yo soy
yo soy venezolana pero tú eres
venezolana pues sí soy venezolano y
entonces esas etiquetas y esas
diferencias van creando lo que yo llamo
una segunda crisis de la ciudad que es
la crisis del miedo
y el miedo nos ha obligado entonces a
abandonar esos espacios de encuentro
esos espacios comunes que nos encantan
de las ciudades
esto fue el martes estábamos justamente
un lindísimo espacio abierto en un
bulevar chito en petare en la ceiba y
ahí pues estábamos empezando a ocuparlo
porque lo queremos transformar y un
minuto después de esa foto unos minutos
más tarde llegaron fuerzas de la misión
anti secuestro y extorsión
armados y tuvimos que rápidamente salir
entonces a veces para ocupar esos
espacios ya sea por temas de violencia
cantidad de cosas se vuelve una
situación compleja a la que vamos
teniendo miedo y entonces nos resignamos
y abandonamos esos espacios y cuando los
abandonamos es muy muy difícil volver a
recuperarlos es muy difícil volver a
decir claro que si se puede vamos a
hacer pero entonces decimos bueno cuando
cambie el gobierno cuando tengamos algo
de plática y pongamos un bombillo y
entonces no sea tan oscuro ese
rinconcito
cuando venga a la alcaldía está acá y
entonces nos echó una mano pero entonces
te consigues como niñas como victoria
que tendrá 11 años vecina de la zona y
ahí está con la foto de ese mismo lugar
explicando por qué hay que recuperar ese
espacio porque hay que quitar el espacio
a la violencia a los muchachos que
consumen drogas y recuperarlo para los
niños jugar y disfrutarlo
entonces cuando tenemos gente como ella
que además te habla con franqueza y
entiende la vulnerabilidad de ese
espacio es cuando uno se motiva y dice
por qué no empezamos con jóvenes desde
los 11 años a empoderar los a
transformar sus espacios públicos y así
será que quizás podamos combatir la
crisis del desencuentro
entonces mi primera actualización es un
poco pensar en cómo empoderamos a estos
jóvenes como les damos herramientas para
que victoria de verdad pueda cambiar ese
espacio público de su comunidad
y desde hace un tiempo empecé a pensar
que todo partía de la identidad de
entender la identidad de donde
pertenezco de por qué por qué por qué es
chévere donde yo vivo porque es linda mi
comunidad y entender esa identidad nos
permite desarrollar un sentido de
pertenencia que finalmente hace que nos
provoquen y nos sintamos motivados a
presentarnos en frente un montón de
adultos y decir las ideas que tenemos
para cambiar nuestra comunidad
y esas ideas idealmente se pueden
convertir en proyectos concretos y
transformación de espacios públicos
concretos para jugar y para alimentar de
los niños
para lograr eso nosotros hemos
desarrollado una metodología que dice
que debemos cumplir con un ciclo de
transformación y un ciclo de
transformación humana desde los jóvenes
que viven en las comunidades pero
también en un ciclo de transformación
del espacio físico como demostración de
esa transformación humana ese ciclo
consta en observar imaginar y
transformar enfocado siempre a los
espacios públicos como máximo ejemplo de
lo maravilloso que es vivir en ciudad
cuando hablamos de observar hablamos de
abrir los ojos les damos cámaras
fotográficas a los niños para que ellos
mismos identifiquen los espacios que
quieren transformar al mismo tiempo que
los van ubicando en un mapa eso le
permite entender la constelación y la
cantidad de lugares que tienen
posibilidades de convertirse en espacios
de encuentro en su comunidad luego
escogemos uno de ellos y entonces
imaginamos qué es lo que puede suceder
allí cuáles son las miles de cosas que
nadie se le ha ocurrido que pueden estar
pasando en ese sitio y las representamos
en maquetas y finalmente las hacemos
realidad y decimos que transformamos
píxel por píxel nuestras
transformaciones no son una gran obra de
infraestructura pero son obras
importantes para la gente que las
concibe desde el primer momento y lo
importante es que cada una de las
personas de la comunidad que participa
pone una especie de pixel en ese lugar
que transformamos esto es un mural cada
niño de esta escuela hizo una cajita que
es una jardinera para transformar por
completo esa pared entonces esta idea
sencilla que en esta escuela es bastante
acotada se transforma en ideas más
grandes como por ejemplo hablemos de
techos verdes de cómo reducir la
temperatura
en los espacios interiores aquí tenemos
un manual el paso a paso muy sencillo de
cómo construir un techo verde en la
escuela y que efectivamente lo
construimos con los niños entonces
cuando yo hablo de empoderar no se trata
solo de darnos cuenta de lo que somos
capaces de hacer y que podemos hacer
sino también de darle herramientas para
lograrlo y esas herramientas se basan
para nosotros como arquitectos del
equipo bueno somos arquitectos
educadores administradores ya somos un
equipo bastante amplio pero para
nosotros esas herramientas se basan en
las herramientas de diseño y básicamente
de transformación física
la muchacha que salía en la foto
anterior michelle ella es una muchacha
que yo conocía hace dos años y medio y
la primera vez que hablamos y estaba en
el taller y me dijo que ya no podía
hacer nada que ya era incapaz de hacer
una maqueta entonces yo más o menos le
pregunté de menos de que quieras hacer
la maqueta ya mismo quiero hacer las
gradas para la cancha de fútbol y entre
las dos venas que le expliqué ya terminó
siendo su gradas y la sonrisa de haber
logrado hacer esa maqueta era fantástica
ese pequeño momento de darle un pequeño
empujoncito a michelle para lograr hacer
su maqueta fue lo que le permitió que un
año después estábamos dando otro taller
en su misma comunidad oa moreno en el
consejo estado aragua y ella guiará a
los niños a aprender a construir un
abecedario con tapas recicladas como las
que aparecen ahí en esta esquina si de
paso en una esquina que peligrosísima
cerca de la casa los malandros que nadie
nosotros ni nos habíamos dado cuenta que
será un espacio pues en esa esquina
estos jóvenes en parte liderados por
michel construyan todo ese escenario de
letras
pero la redundancia de ese abecedario
donde los niños pueden aprender a leer
brincando de letra en letra entonces
historias como la de michel son las que
nos muestran que si es posible empoderar
a los jóvenes que hay que empezar por
darse cuenta de que si puede hacerlo
pero hay que darles herramientas también
para hacerlo
la segunda palabra clave para mí es
reconocer hasta ahora hemos hablado del
liderazgo personal de michelle pero
hablemos también de como michelle
reconoce a su comunidad como obedecemos
los miedos y las etiquetas y en varias
escalas en la escala de nuestros
talleres nosotros
invitamos a los jóvenes a visitar a los
vecinos y preguntarles que quieren hacer
en su comunidad escogimos este espacio
que es lo que quisiera hacer por ejemplo
no sé si alguno de ustedes alguna vez le
han preguntado les ha tocado la
presencia a qué te gusta jugar preguntas
tan sencillas son importantes porque si
vamos a poner un parque en la comunidad
vamos a ver que hay a los juegos que les
gusta la mayoría que haya entonces los
jóvenes empiezan a reconocer a sus
vecinos pero también en otra escala
urbana y tenemos hace dos años se nos
ocurrió hacer un proyecto diferente
decidimos invitar a 150 voluntarios
de varios sitios para trabajar en josé
félix ribas en una escalera que sube el
equivalente a diez pisos de un edificio
invitamos a vecinos de la escalera por
supuesto sobre todo niños y también
invitamos a familias de la organización
de jóvenes empresarios ellos escribieron
varios meses antes y al inscribirse
estaban ya ubicados en una cuadrilla
donde trabajaban dos jóvenes de un
adulto y un muchacho de josé félix ribas
y un adulto y un muchacho de fuera de
estas familias de jóvenes empresarios y
en lo que debían hacer en alguna mañana
transformar por completo esa escalera
como ven en las fotos que ya tenían dos
colores amarillo y rojo que son dos
colores que habían colocado los vecinos
unos a favor del chavismo otros a favor
de primero justicia y habían pintado
pues aquí ya tenía un acuerdo que no le
va a pintar de un solo color sino había
llegado un punto medio entonces querían
hacer algo más porque ya se estaba
poniendo un poquito fea la pintura
entonces decidimos escribir una historia
es un cuento venezolano precioso que se
llama azul rojo y justamente cuenta la
historia de cómo llegar a puntos medios
y ceder a veces para llegar a acuerdos
entre vecinos y la isla esto que va
contando de una mamá y papá que le gusta
el azul y el rojo y al final el niño
dice que le gusta el morado
entonces al final de ese día maravilloso
que la escalera quedó toda escrita con
este cuento precioso de mireia está
agujas que se llama zoom rojo
una de las cosas más bellas fue ver como
los niños se han transformado en este
proceso y entonces son dos niños uno de
jose felix y otro no es de jose felix y
que no de jose felix cuenta después de
trabajar toda la mañana con él él se dio
cuenta de algo muy importante él se dio
cuenta que el barrio no era lo que él
pensaba que era una cara una montaña con
puras casitas sino que el barrio era más
bien igual que su edificio era como un
gran edificio donde las escaleras y
todos los callejones eran como los
pasillos de su edificio pero la
diferencia era que en esos pasillos su
compañero de trabajo saludaba por nombre
y apellido a cada persona que pasaba
entonces esta experiencia de
reconocernos y de aprender unos de los
otros para mí lo que un poco lo que me
ayudaba a entender es que siempre un
aprendizaje de parte y parte cuando
unimos esas partes que parecen estar
segregadas o separadas
y la tercera palabra es recuperar o
decíamos ayer en una conversación no
abandonar porque es muy difícil a veces
se delante la violencia entre las
amenazas incluso ante la lluvia ante
tantas cosas una vez estamos
construyendo un parque y nos empezó a
llover y no podíamos terminar pero no
ceder ante nada este es el caso de
jessica jessica vive la pretención de
paria en una comunidad rural se llama el
rincón y hace un año exactamente yo fue
a esa escuela para ver qué podíamos
hacer para mejorar su escuela y dijo que
yo escuela hacía falta un parque y había
demasiados niños y no hay ni un columpio
donde andar entonces nos imaginamos en
uno de los terrenos que podría haber un
parque y fuimos unos meses después
hicimos todas estas propuestas de parque
para esa escuela de las propuestas había
de todos no se pueden imaginar todo
ghanés columpios techos que hacían
sombra cantidad de cosas con esas ideas
hicimos un proyecto arquitectónico y
terminamos construyendo ese parte estas
son unas
lo llamamos el bosque de colores con
mangueras llenas de vic y vicky pero
este el terreno donde se construyó el
parque y esto fue lo que quedó está un
poquito oscuro a la foto pero bueno hay
seis columpios puentes de cauchos mesas
para estudiar al aire libre techos
verdes etcétera
pero un vecino se llama davidson dijo
aquí no vamos a estar esperando ya ha
pasado uno dos tres meses para que venga
a la alcaldía echarnos una mano a sacar
el barro eso no va a pasar vamos a
hacerlo nosotros y agarro con un amigo
es solo entre dos personas y limpiaron
toda la casa y la pintaron pasaron 17
años y llegamos contratando espacios a
esta comunidad y entonces invitamos a
los niños a imaginar cómo podíamos
mejorar aún más esa casa y que esa casa
tuviera la identidad que merecía en su
comunidad entonces entre bastantes
propuestas de maquetas esta fue una de
las ganadoras donde vemos la fachada
llena de colores esos colores
representan los diablos danzantes de
naiguatá
y para ellos es una tradición muy muy
importante entonces esa fue por supuesto
una vida de ganadoras y en efecto la
pudimos construir con ayuda de más de
150 voluntarios de la comunidad y de
fuera que nos apoyaron a construirlas
con tapitas de esas de refrescos que a
veces llamamos basura pero en el equipo
de alguna persona que siempre dice nada
es basura y nos hace guardar tapitas y
cartones y todo tipo de cosas entonces
fíjense como con estas tapitas logramos
transformar por completo toda la fachada
de la casa del deporte al igual que
construir mobiliario para dentro de esa
casa hacer una pérgola para protegerse
del sol entre un montón de cosas más y
finalmente re inauguramos esta casa para
el uso de la comunidad pero esta vez no
fueron davidson y su amigo sino que
fueron 16 jóvenes entre 10 y 15 años de
esa comunidad que promovieron ese cambio
que a su vez arrastraron a 150 personas
más para cambiar
entonces yo creo que hoy una de las
cosas más importantes es preguntarnos
qué es lo que está creando esa crisis
del desencuentro qué es lo que la crea
para mí a nivel de la ciudad el espacio
público qué es lo que yo sé pero para
ustedes quizás es otra cosa y para mí
son tres cosas empoderarnos desde el
espacio personal recuperar esos espacios
y no abandonar los espacios que ya hemos
conquistado y finalmente una de las más
importantes es reconocernos para poder
trabajar en equipo gracias
[Aplausos]